SARAH HANSEN: Could you
tell us a little bit
about the history and
development of 18.065,
this new course?
GILBERT STRANG: Yes, OK.
So this was my adventure into
the subject of deep learning.
So that's a special part
of machine learning,
a highly important part.
It's in the newspaper
all the time.
And students are graduating
knowing about the deep learning
and getting good jobs.
And it's really amazing.
So and then the
other beautiful part
is that it depends so
heavily on linear algebra.
SARAH HANSEN: You've been known
to say, "I certainly learned
that projects are far
better than exams.
Students ask their own questions
and write their own programs.
From now on, projects."
GILBERT STRANG: That's right.
Yeah.
Sort of late to learn this
because with the 18.06
linear algebra, totally
conventional course
with maybe three exams during
the semester and a final exam.
And maybe that's appropriate.
But it's changing.
And then with this new course,
where the computer's involved,
and you--
for example, so I ask
everybody to do a project.
There is no final exam.
Actually, there's
no exam at all.
I shouldn't like to say this.
But it's really what the subject
is is having an idea of how--
OK, I'll use deep
learning for something.
SARAH HANSEN: What did
that feel like to try
something new pedagogically?
GILBERT STRANG: Oh, it's fun.
You know, I like teaching.
And this is a subject
where students
just come from everywhere.
Because they know
what stuff to learn.
And they've heard about it.
And they-- some of
them know more than me.
And then those students
write even better projects.
Yeah, it's just-- so I do the
lectures for the first three
quarters of the course.
And then I try to
get them to present,
which is a great
experience for them,
though it takes a little
urging to get them.
But, yeah, yeah, it's
really just wonderful.
SARAH HANSEN: What
insights have you
gained about having more
of a student-led course
and a project-based course?
Anything that other--
GILBERT STRANG: You
realize, slowly but finally,
that that's how people
learn, by doing.
That you couldn't
give them a better way
to learn than to
create a project.
Usually, it's on some
topic they know about
or they're interested
in, like, how do you
find a criminal in
a bunch of people?
Yeah, it's just a very
effective way to learn.
And it's something that
gets remembered, where
doing exam questions
that I might make up,
sort of mathy questions,
I don't know if that's
remembered 10 years later.
But I think people's
projects are.
SARAH HANSEN: Is there
anything you learned
from teaching it this way?
Like something that maybe
went wrong in the logistics
of facilitating these
projects that next time you
want to do differently?
GILBERT STRANG: Well, sure.
I didn't have any idea
what to expect really.
And maybe the students
didn't either.
They said, what's a project?
Well, one student
had said unwisely,
when are the projects due?
I thought, what's that?
I mean, I hadn't even
thought about projects.
So I was like, OK.
All right.
You asked for it.
So we decided that the last--
the end of the
semester, the final day
of class, which
is two weeks away,
projects are due to come in.
And then some of the class
is able, has a chance,
to present their project in the
last weeks, but not everybody
because it's a big class.
So it starts with each
student or each group--
it could be two or three
students together--
sends me an email
about their plan.
And I respond.
I usually respond, wonderful.
And maybe I have an idea
of a reference or two
that they could look at.
But and then they just do it.
Yeah, it's really very nice.
SARAH HANSEN: Do you give them
any feedback along the way?
GILBERT STRANG: If
they ask for it, yeah.
And if I-- you know,
usually they'll
know more about their
subject than me.
But maybe what they
learn also is presenting.
That's an important thing.
So it's really just more--
it's richer than taking an exam.
Well, the viewer may
think, OK, Professor Strang
says no more exams.
I don't know if--
so don't quote me
on that, please.
SARAH HANSEN: OK.
In 18.065, in one
of the videos, you
talk about grading
students' work.
And you tell them
that, although this
is important to
grade their work,
it's not your main concern.
That your main concern is
actually learning with them.
GILBERT STRANG: Right.
This is what I want
to say the most.
And I say it to
every class I teach
near the start of the semester.
My feeling about what my job
is is to teach you things
or to join with you in learning
things, as has happened today.
It's not to grade you.
So typically, the first few
days of class, these guys
ask, you know, what's the
class average going to be?
How are we going to be graded?
I don't have any
answers for that stuff.
So I say what is totally
true, that I'm not--
I don't feel my main
job is to grade them.
That my job is to teach
them or learn with them.
And that's what
I continue to do.
And gradually, they
begin to believe.
You know, at the beginning,
they still think, OK, but he's
got to give me a
B, or a C, or an A.
But really, that's not what
18.065 is about, a grade.
It's just not.
SARAH HANSEN: What advice do
you have for new professors
starting out in teaching?
GILBERT STRANG: Well,
probably this interview
has expressed most
of the thoughts
I have about in the class.
Yeah, yeah.
Use big chalk, especially
if it's a large class.
It helps your writing get--
your writing looks
impressively level, even,
because of the chalk.
And don't rush.
And don't think you have
to cover everything.
Just stay with the class.
Yeah.
Well, so again, it's
the best job possible.